hey I'm Hannah Simone and today I'm
going to be cooking macaroni to fundo
for you macaroni to fundo is from the
island of Cyprus which is where I'm from
so growing up eating macaroni into funda
on the island there's only two places
you could get it and not one of them is
a restaurant you can get it at someone's
home they cook it for you or you go to a
bakery and I know that sounds weird
because here you think of a bakery you
think of bread and then that's it but in
Cyprus when you go to the bakery they
sell everything like they have a section
where they make cooked local foods so
ever in Cyprus you want macaroni to
fundo and you go to a restaurant a sport
they're gonna think you're crazy
you go to a little bakery they're open
24 hours a day and you go get some echo
tone you're there so I think people
think with dishes like this because it
feels so special that it's for special
occasions I make it like once a week I
love it so much it's so yummy and then I
take it to work at new girl and I sit
there in my trailer and I eat my coat on
eautiful know it reminds me of being
back on the island so the ingredients
might seem a little out of the ordinary
pork mint cinnamon the halloumi but
almost all of those you can just go get
at your grocery store
halloumi cheese - Cypriot is what
mozzarella is - Italian it's just like
our staple cheese what's great about it
is that when you put it in the makedonia
you add no salt to any part of the dish
not into the pork mix not into the
bechamel because the cheese provides all
of that that actual natural salty flavor
so I take four toothpicks and put it one
in each corner to create a little prop
tent and then I put the aluminum foil
over it and that way nothing sticks to
my bechamel and takes it away from what
could go into my belly so when you eat
macaroni into fundo you want to speak
Greek but you might not know any Greek
so I'm gonna help you out sag out Bowl
sag out ball means I love you
there's no way to take a small bite of
delicious food
okay go make it what are you doing so
delicious miss Ann you're eating it's so
rude what oh yes
[Music]